[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast please hit subscribe I deeply
appreciate all the times that it's
clicked the subscribers means that we're
on the right path and it also helps us
get bigger guests and be able to just do
a better job for you so please hit
subscribe if you would today on the show
is Sal DiStefano he is a trainer has
been a trainer for a couple of decades
knows so much about really psychology
human nature the body he has a show that
I've been listening to Forever mind pump
TV so it's him and a few guys that sort
of hash it out about various different
topics that are going on and then always
getting into some element of fitness and
then they have collars on where they ask
their specific questions pertaining to
them which is always so interesting so
I've just been learning so much from
them it's actually the the strength
program that I'm that I'm doing right
now is through mind pump and it's a
program called maps go to their website
and pick one of I don't know there must
be 20 different programs I'm always was
trying to find the truth out like what
what is what is it that I need to be
doing that could be sort of better here
or there and I tell you what I've
learned so much about gaining muscle
strength training you know what kind of
workout programs are good for you which
one's bad and what kind of signal it's
sending the body essentially and what
mechanism is is activated in the body
that leads to essentially feeling better
being healthier leaning out being
stronger and having a better hormonal
profile really powerful stuff I hope you
enjoyed the episode please let me know
what you think in the comments
today's pretty intense partner is
athletic greens I take ag1 by athletic
greens literally every day covering my
nutritional basis for the day couldn't
be any easier which is why I trust
athletic greens just a mix of one scoop
of ag1 with water first thing in the
morning done I also like that it costs
less than three dollars a day pretty
good if you ask me it's a really
effective daily habit with the highest
quality sourced ingredients win-win if a
comprehensive solution is what you need
from your supplement routine then
athletic greens is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase go to athleticgreens.com pretty
intense that's athleticgreens.com pretty
intense check it out so what is
something that gets you sick do you you
have kids right so it could be kids
right they bring they're a cesspool of
germs the amount of hours I've spent
listening to your show I know a lot
about you and the boys you know mental
health is spent in the gym for the most
part so it's like how often do you run
yourself into the ground and go [__]
went a little far with that probably
should have taken more rest days yeah
you know that's always a struggle I
think uh what what
people who are Fitness Fanatics I've
talked about this before on the show by
the way thanks for listening to our
that's so cool that you listen to our
show oh for sure we've all been a fan of
yours for a long time yeah to hear that
so it's kind of cool thanks
um I think when you really enjoy Fitness
um and you do it
um for years and years and years you're
always playing that
that dance of the right amount and then
you kind of tend to go towards maybe a
little too much and that's something
that you always kind of need to check
and regulate because what is too much
changes
depending on the context of what's going
on in your life you know sleep stress
diet
um you know obviously as you age things
start to change
so it's like a constant continual
journey of figuring out what the right
amount is paying attention to those
signs
um and that's uh that's a that can be a
struggle sometimes especially for me
because I love it I love the process of
working out and so I tend to
push a little too hard
often and you know I know what the signs
are and sometimes I'll ignore them a
little bit to try and you know hit that
new PR or whatever
but uh but I'm not as bad as I used to
be that's for sure it used to be
I would wait until my body was screaming
before I would back off yeah now it's
like okay my my joints bother me a
little bit or I'm a little too sore and
then I'll back off uh but yeah that's
that's just that's always that game it's
like what's the right amount versus too
much yeah I'm curious I want to kind of
go chop down bottom up just like what
that looks like for someone because
everyone's gonna fall in the middle
there's kind of like a Max like
you know even with all the modalities
possible like here's what's re here's
what is within reason and here's like
the minimum if you want gains but
um you know let's start there like I
mean if somebody is in there
um you know if somebody's fit somebody
has options they cold plunge they which
I know you don't want a cold plunge if
you want to gain muscle because it stops
the it's uh what's the mechanism with
cold plunge Yeah well yeah no that's
good not necessarily
um so cold plunging will reduce the
inflammatory signaling process which is
a part of the process that tells the
body to build muscle but uh there is a
plus side to that as well right because
uh look you at one point you were
competing at a very high level and being
able to increase your body's ability to
handle more stress may you could train
and practice more right so is there a
benefit to practicing uh exercises more
frequently and the answer to that is
absolutely especially for people who are
learning new skills or perfecting uh new
techniques so if you could reduce the
inflammatory signaling and then add more
to compensate so you're at the same as
you were before in terms of the signal
except you're able to practice more so
it's not as black and white as don't do
that it won't build muscle it's more
like hey if I do that I can probably
squat a few times more a week or I could
probably practice that lift that I'm
trying to learn I see more that week so
it's not so so so cut and dry so the
damage to the muscle you know you kind
of have a certain amount of muscle
building that have happens in response
to that inflammation to go and repair
and then if you cold plunge you actually
you know you're still missing a little
bit of that repair time but the fact
that you can do it all again actually is
worth you know 30 percent more or
something like that you're not getting
the maximum out of that one lift but it
still is worth something a little bit
more to be able to go and add volume
again 100 so think of an athlete uh an
athlete who's trying to perform at a
high level to practice their skills very
often okay so you're a pitcher the more
you can pitch the better you'll be at
pitching so it's not just the I'm
strengthening my arm and able to throw
the ball real hard if I got to continue
because it's a technique right it's a
skill so if I could do something that
allows me to practice more uh that's
better so that's true also with just
exercise a lot of people don't look at
exercise like like a skill but running
is a skill lifting is a skill chill
rowing is a skill swimming is a skill
and for the average person listening
they're like well what's the difference
if I'm I'm just working out and getting
sore and sweating the better you can
perform a particular movement the better
you you have mastered the skill I should
say of a particular movement the more
benefit you'll reap from it so if you
can run with better technique and skill
then you're going to get much more out
of running than you would with let's say
worse skill or technique so okay
um you know I'm on a cold plunge or do
these other things that maybe reduce the
muscle building signal by it's and it's
a small percentage but it's like three
percent or four percent it's nothing oh
that's it oh my God I'm gonna Lift Every
Day why is it only three days a week
full body it should be six yeah yes yeah
people get caught up in this kind of
stuff it's pretty it's pretty funny to
me
um it's it's not nine out of ten times
it's not so cut and dry you really have
to look at the individual and consider
the whole picture and these studies that
they tend to perform on stuff like this
are like eight 12 weeks I mean eight to
twelve weeks can tell you something but
it doesn't tell you everything
especially if this is what you'll be
doing for the rest of your life
um you know you got to look at that in
in context so what is a reasonable
volume I know you your programs I've
looked through them I bought two I'm
doing aesthetic but I think I bought
anabolic first is that is it's like six
days a week of lifting yeah um aesthetic
is aesthetic would be about sick
aesthetic is three full body days within
a few Focus sessions yes yeah yeah I did
my tricep Focus session I know I'm sure
you invented the focus in the trigger
sessions because you're like what am I
supposed to do with all these other days
well really what they what they are is
uh there's a few different mechanisms
that signal the body to adapt uh there's
a few things to focus on one of them is
intensity another one is just simple
volume uh there's metabolic stress and
so what you can do and and the thing
that you always have to consider the
the uh I think the the thing that might
get in the way is your body's ability to
adapt heal and recover
so we have to look at okay what can we
do and when when does the recovery start
to become a problem
training intensely you'll hit that wall
pretty quickly but can I do movement uh
in a less intense way that doesn't
necessarily compromise recovery in in
fact many times improves or enhances
recovery and still rather don't think of
it ascending the muscle building signal
but rather maintaining the muscle
building signal so when you look at the
data on like if you were to do a workout
today they could test something called
muscle protein synthesis and we see it
Spike relatively quickly after a workout
and then it starts to drop after about
48 hours or so it starts to go down to
Baseline
but we can't just Hammer the body every
single day so is there a way to kind of
keep that signal above Baseline without
compromising recovery too much and yes
that's lower intensity
type workouts so like a trigger session
would be that or even a focus that would
be something like that so it's like
these lower intensity
workouts where I'm doing exercises don't
that don't necessarily cause as much
damage like these little joint exercises
you know machines where I'm focusing
more on let's say the pump or the
connection versus those days where I'm
really kind of getting after it I don't
know [__] squats feel pretty damn hard
to me okay there's not they're not for
sissies I was downstairs trying to teach
my mom [__] squats and um they're hard
because she's hiking the Grand Canyon in
a few months and so she needs to build
her legs up and strength a little bit
and I'm like all right Mom these are
nuts for sissies but here they are
um so uh yes there's there's plenty of
ways to make it make it difficult but
um so that's so what's the most volume
program that you have because I'm
guessing that would be your maximum
volume recommendation oh we have a
program called ped
um uh that is a Double Split routine so
you're working out twice a day uh you're
training each body part two or three
days a week it's a super high volume
extremely Advanced routine that I would
say
is probably for about one percent of our
audience so it's like the super
genetically gifted
um athlete where there are people out
there that just they this is a lot this
a lot of people don't get this either
this this is actually quite important
even especially to communicate to women
because sometimes women are afraid not
so much today
as much today I should say but still you
see this where they're just afraid of of
strength training because they think
they're gonna just build these huge
muscles until you start trying and then
you realize how hard it is and then
you're I mean yeah you could put the
most um you could put I put lots of
effort into it and I'm like okay
and you just look sculpted
um there's this genetic uh variance when
it comes to muscle building where on one
end you have
you know you have muscular issues actual
genetic deficiencies and then on the
other hand you have these genetic
anomalies where they just without even
working out they are stronger and more
muscular than most people and they're
about as rare as a seven foot tall
person so if you think about how how
many times you've run into someone who's
seven foot tall in the real world which
is never
that's how rare but they exist there are
very few and far between you go on
social media it looks like everybody's
that person but in real life it's like
super super rare in my career of
managing gems for I don't know two and a
half decades or so I can honestly say
I've probably known
maybe two people who kind of fit that
bill I remember I used to have this guy
that worked for me
he was a porter so he cleaned the
bathrooms and stuff and uh and I used to
watch him uh he'd work out every once in
a while in the gym and I'd see him do
Skull Crushers so that's like a that's a
tricep extension exercise with 225
pounds which is just uh insane and he
was just so muscular and I thought man
this guy must be just dialed in open it
out oh he was eating Pop-Tarts at
McDonald's and just
he was just a genetic he was one of
those people that just he just got those
those jeans that just his body problems
with those people they don't need to
work out because they look
that's just their build can you imagine
if they put a little effort in oh well
if they do then you got yourself a
professional athlete exactly you know
you you've uh I'm sure I know you've
definitely run into professional
athletes you ever watch a
lineman you know a 280 or 300 pound
lineman run it's terrifying you know you
see a huge human being run full speed
faster than anybody you've ever seen
it's like this doesn't make any sense
it's like looking at a rhinoceros it
just doesn't make sense yeah but those
people exist but most of us are
somewhere in the middle yep meaning you
could dedicate your entire life to
trying to build muscle and what you'll
end up with is a very sculpted
uh healthy physique is what you'll end
up
so that being the maximum and you know
for those rare people is what you
recommend as far as a split goes for
someone who really enjoys the gym that's
outside of that one percent or less of
people that have you know genetic gifts
um is it is three full body days truly
the right amount because you're hitting
everything three times if you're willing
to spend the time in the gym or is it
better to is there another option that
would kind of continue with that muscle
synthesis protein synthesis
um that happens within that sort of what
24 to 72 hour window you see I think you
said after every workout is where your
body's repairing and building muscle but
after that it loses the signal yeah
that's a great question there's a lot of
things we have to consider when you uh
ask a question like that because I
trained people
for years and years and years so the
number one thing that I consider
is what will the person be able to do uh
consistently for the rest of their life
that's the most important thing to
consider so if somebody asked me you
know what's the best type of cardio the
one that you'll do is first okay so
that being said
most people not Fitness Fanatics because
remember Fitness Fanatics we love
exercising we love working out we love
the whole thing the average person would
exercise and work out to improve the
quality of their life so really they're
using it as a tool to have a better life
move better or be a better spouse you
know a better parent just feel healthy
not because they love it so much for the
sake of it but rather they love what it
does to the rest of life
the average person in terms of
structured workouts because there's
activity and then they're structured
workouts
the average person we could probably say
if we do a good job we can get them to
do about two days a week consistently
okay three days a week is excellent but
most people on average if you really
average it out with missed workouts and
stuff we're probably going to do about
two days a week
so you're looking at about two full body
workouts full body because it allows you
to practice these core exercises and
movements to to maximize the skill it
allows you to do the movements that
really give you the most bang for your
buck you're only in there twice a week
again there's activity as well so I
would encourage that person to find ways
to inject activity into their daily
lives so like one example would be
my favorite would be a 10 minute walk
after breakfast lunch and dinner I've
had a lot of success with uh you know
getting people to be able to do that it
seems to be easy uh for people to
maintain it turns out you know 30 it it
turns into about 30 minutes if you add
it all up it helps with blood sugar it's
you know just when you get the data on
it makes a big difference
so about two days a week three days a
week would be amazing
um for for most people all right volume
wise what does that look like
uh the average person if they did
you know three sets of an exercise per
body part twice a week they would get
pretty far they would get pretty far
they would feel good they would gain
some strength they would have the
mobility
uh they they would they would feel good
they would they would reap a lot of the
benefits of strength training okay now
if somebody was like wow I really like
this like I really want to be able to do
more I'm enjoying this well then you can
add a third day now you're doing about
nine sets on the upper end
you're looking at about 16 to 18 total
sets per week but now we're getting
again into that kind of Fitness fanatic
uh level but Danica I'm telling you I
trained people for a long time
professionals uh and stay-at-home moms
and dads and I got people really far
which was two days a week like really
far
like feeling good really good strength
you know I would get guys to be able to
deadlift twice their body weight I'd be
able to get them into be able to squat
their body weight with just a couple
days a week you know the beauty of
strength training is it's
I like to look at strength training like
uh investing
uh you know if you want to let's say
become wealthy there's a couple ways you
could do that one is to work more hours
uh where you just you know you okay I
make x amount of dollars per hour I'm
going to work more and more and more
hours the other way is to take your
money and put it somewhere so that that
wherever you put it that investment
starts to make money for you
strength training is more like that okay
it's sending the signal then your body
does the work for you after that again
you earns the calories maintains because
once you put the muscle on it also
doesn't take that much to keep it I was
like shocked to hear you talk about the
amount of effort it takes the amount of
reps and sets that it takes to maintain
muscle once you've generated it it's
something like a tenth or something
right it's like significantly less so
it's a total investment it's crazy you
might have even experienced this where
you'll you'll take a week or two off
you'll go back to the gym and you're as
strong or stronger oh yeah well I take a
week or two off I lean out and then I go
back at least just as strong yeah it's
wild so and that's there's a few things
we could talk about with that I mean
there's there's muscle memory uh which
is a really well documented uh phenomena
if you've ever broken a limb and had to
wear a cast you've experienced this
where you take the cast off and your leg
or your arm is like totally atrophied
and then in a very short period of time
the muscle seems to come back by itself
it's just like it you know evolutionary
adaptive process uh that we've evolved
with boys are the ones that break your
limbs us girls we just get our egos hurt
yeah right our hearts you've never
broken a limb no really
wow that's awesome uh but you know I
think people some people can can it's a
really interesting phenomenon
once you gain you know let's say you
work out for a full year and you do a
really good job and you gain let's say
10 pounds of of lean body mass so
amazing opid more Thai fashion
metabolism then for whatever reason you
stop working out for a couple months
maybe you get sick who knows you lose
all of it then you get back to the gym
you'll get it back in a month whatever
what it took you a year to gain
when you lose it it'll take you a month
uh to gain it back and then to keep it
the amount of training to keep it is
very little and what you'll find which
which is this is really cool I remember
one of the main like one of the big
questions I would get from Members when
I would
tour people around my gyms and stuff as
they'd say well what happens after I get
in shape then and I stop working out I'm
like well you get out of shape you know
so people are always looking for that
like you know can I do this and then get
those permanent results well that
doesn't exist but boy does this get kind
of weird weirdly close like you could
train yourself for years and then
maintain it with very little work and
effort and this is well documented
there's just lots of ways to support
this just doesn't take as much to
maintain now this isn't true for every
physical uh attribute like stamina
stamina you lose very quickly like if
you
if you're trying to build lots of
endurance and stamina and then you take
a week or two off you'll come back and
you'll notice a considerable
considerable reduction right strength
takes a while actually to to go away uh
muscle doesn't you don't lose it nearly
as quickly and the longer you have it I
like to tell this story if you you
probably heard me tell this if you since
you listen to the show I remember
I used to have this Wellness Studio
and uh it used to be next door to this
like breakfast joint that was really
popular so people would line up for the
breakfast joint and I'd see them outside
my door while I was training clients
well anyway there was this
this is like five foot seven like older
guy and he kept looking in the window
and then he you know he walked in I was
training a client he had a Russian
accent
and he goes can I can I try this you
know it was a kettlebell it was like a
70 pound kettlebell I said yeah you can
I mean yeah sure you could see what it
looks like or whatever and he grabbed it
and he like pressed it up in the air
brought it down and he was I want to say
he was in his 70s and he had these like
little muscular like forearms I mean he
was a little overweight but you could I
I mean just I know I can look at
somebody and be like this guy has a past
or history yeah he was like a lumberjack
or something like this guy did something
seriously manual he was a he was an
Olympic weightlifter for the Soviet
Union
he was telling me and I'm like do you
exercise now do you work out now he goes
oh no not really you know I don't really
do it as much but I remember looking at
this guy's forearms and his body and
it's like there's this like there's
almost this permanence
because he trained for years and years
and years at such a yeah high level
um there's something called muscle fiber
hyperplasia uh that now we've
observed and it's where you're it's like
you increase the amount of muscle fibers
you have after years of training that's
all the more reason to lift weights and
I was at the CrossFit Games last past
weekend and the guys kind of look like
they could look in real life if they
worked out
but the girls don't look anything like
they would look like if they were in
real life working out and I was like
maybe that's just because girls don't
lift like most girls just don't lift so
they it's not even close to the normal
amount of workouts or the kind that they
would ever do
um but such an incredible investment and
I'm just I just love the fact that I can
eat way more amen you just yeah you get
the meal on the head uh it's faster
metabolism what a great buffer against
uh the Modern Life modern life is like
we're surrounded by all this food and an
activity you know your daily life is
inactive just the way that we've
designed the world now
so a faster metabolism is like a
wonderful insurance policy you know it
wasn't great thousands of years ago I
think people
need to understand that 50 000 years ago
having a fast metabolism is not a great
idea yeah true that's totally true
you're not going to find food
uh everywhere but now a fast metabolism
is a great thing to have because there's
food everywhere you want to be able to
burn it off in fact when you look at the
when we talk about the things that are
quote unquote unhealthy you know like
like sugar and certain types of fats
when you eat in what's called a calorie
deficit in other words you eat less than
your body's burning like at least 90
percent of the negatives that are
associated with those things
10 are are erased from the fact that you
burn it off
so a faster metabolism is this amazing
uh insurance policy and you mentioned
you mentioned uh you know women and
girls don't lift weights
it's because they've been marketed to so
heavily that like being small
is good uh you know losing weight on the
scale
is good you know if you build 10 pounds
of muscle
and lose 10 pounds of body fat you've
lost no weight but you're smaller oh my
God I mean I love that story that you
tell I've heard you tell a couple of
times where women will come into your
come in to train and they have a number
that they want to hit and you're like
I'll train you for free or something
like that if you can guess how much this
woman weighs and she comes over and they
all guess way too high because she's
just freaking a brick house and um
they're shocked like she was what she's
tiny and she weighed like 135 and
everybody thought she was like 105
pounds or something yeah they all
thought she was like 100 pounds but
she's actually 135 pounds yeah I mean
that's just amazing muscle is dance like
again if you gain 10 pounds of muscle
lost 10 pounds of body fat you would
lose about a quarter of the size so it
takes up roughly you know three quarters
of the space so muscle's dense plus
muscle gives you shape so you have
rounder glutes yeah posture more
sculpted arms and then she totally
conveys leanness too like I've said a
long time ago like you can change the
size of your body if you want to go run
but you're not going to the only way
you're gonna change the shape of your
body is with weights it's the most
targeted form of exercise where you can
get as close as possible to sculpting
yourself or you can look in the mirror
and say I want more
you know shape here and I want more
rounds here and I want more tightness
here so there's targeted specific
exercises
that'll allow you to do that and then
here's the biggest one is uh hormones
hormone balance is a big deal hormones
uh you know they tell us how to feel
they help direct fat storage or muscle
gain they they influence cognitive
function
if you're telling your body to build
muscle and you're feeding yourself
appropriately to do so the one of the
first things your body does is it
organizes its hormones in a way to be
able to do so what is that hormone think
about that Cascade effect that the
hormones are now being informed they are
and and if you think about uh and this
is true what is the best hormone profile
or what does a muscle building hormone
profile look like in both men and women
it's the kind of hormone profile you had
when you were like 18 years old right
right higher growth hormone it's more
appropriate cortisol it's a balance
between estrogen and progesterone it's
adequate levels of testosterone also
important in women thyroid function
thyroid function so women are you know
and this is especially important well
it's important for both men and women
you're seeing this this is actually
affecting men quite a bit now but women
will talk about this quite a bit because
women experience hormone fluctuations
and then of course mental pause is a big
shift or telling your body to build
muscle you will blunt a lot of those
like like muscle is one of the best ways
to do that like talk about some of the
things that affect women endometriosis
PCOS
um it's all of that is directly
connected to insulin resistance you want
to improve your insulin sensitivity
build some muscle there's nothing
that'll do it better because muscle is a
storage vessel for sugar glycogen which
comes from sugar
it's also one of the most insulin
sensitive tissues on the body in fact
they have studies on obese individuals
where they don't have them lose anyway
they just build a little bit of muscle
and you see these significant
improvements
in blood sugar levels like no other form
of exercise does this as directly as
just telling your body to build a little
bit of muscle it's just not marketed to
women like it should be so with blood
sugar and insulin and this whole loop I
mean I spent a hot second like try
wearing a CGM to check my blood sugar
check in if I went into ketosis using
fasting and
um it
trying to not have any increase in my
blood sugar like that being the goal
which then you quickly realize fat is
pretty much the answer fat and walking
after you eat right pretty much the
pretty much the answer to that problem
but then you know through my interviews
and people and Curiosities and then I'm
spending a hot second chatting with Paul
saladino about
um about all of this and
um he's like you shouldn't worry about
your blood sugar spiking it's normal you
eat something it goes up it's got to
come down though so is that a is it
actually healthy to have a blood sugar
increase and decrease or is it more of
like sometimes it's okay but that is
actually what create creates the insulin
resistance is the system of producing
the insulin to bring the blood sugar
down just gets worn out yeah well uh
both you
there's a lot of context that we have to
consider there
um spikes within a certain range are
normal drop in a certain range are good
you don't want to get these extreme
fluctuations
even if you're otherwise healthy because
it does influence behaviors this is
important to consider
if you get really high spikes and drops
you're probably going to feel uh
irritable you're going to get Cravings
you're going to feel great and that all
tends to drive behaviors that aren't so
healthy so it's like okay I want to eat
more more Cravings uh or I want to eat
more food or I feel irritable or not as
energetic so I'm not going to exercise
as much so that's why that's so
important but you know what you said
about like walking after a meal what
you're doing is you're eating
the the sugar from the meal gets put
into the blood the the walking or
movement it's imagine the muscles are
like sponges okay so this is a kind of a
good analogy it's way more complex than
this but
the muscles are Contracting and relaxing
and it's literally your muscles like
sponges are sucking it up they're
sucking up that blood sugar but if you
eat and sit there and don't move it's
almost like it has nowhere to go uh I
heard this interesting quote from Peter
attia he's a brilliant
he said the difference between uh you
and a person who has blood sugar issues
that are so bad that they lose like
fingers okay so like diabetes right
where you can lose limbs the difference
between a healthy person and that person
is a teaspoon of sugar
in the blood so is it just how your body
deals with it is essentially what he
what the the the the truth of it is it's
not the amount of sugar necessarily it's
where does it go right are your muscles
able to suck it up is your liver able to
process it right or is it just sitting
there floating around uh in your in your
blood and then insulin resistance is
because insulin drives the sugar to the
tissues of your body but if you're you
don't have big storage capacity you
don't have very much muscle you're not
moving much it kind of sits around in
the blood you need more insulin to do
that and over time your body becomes
resistant self-reacting
I'm curious I was going to ask about
this a little later on when I ask about
some Diet stuff but we might as well
just continue with what makes sense at
the moment so then enter in metformin
zempic
wegov and
they increase insulin correct at least I
understand that ozempic does
yeah they work by increasing insulin
sensitivity so here's what I'll say
about uh some of these things first off
metformin's been around for a long time
it's actually one of the medications so
we know what it does and what it doesn't
do there are some potential negatives uh
but uh there are some some positives uh
some are glutide and these other what
are known as glp-1 agonists uh very
interesting uh peptides they seem to be
the most effective I guess you put them
in a I don't know medical interventions
uh for weight loss and for you know for
fat loss if you combine it with other
changes in your lifestyle uh but I will
say this they're not substitutes uh for
just you know exercise and eating right
and there's another part to this too
first off they're not Miracle drugs uh
they're not Miracles they sure look like
it on people yeah well
uh you know let me ask you this you've
been working out for a long time if you
were to list the top five reasons why
you still work out
you know looking you know fit is
probably it might not make the top five
it's probably more like mental health
and feeling good yeah function feeling
good mental Clarity good for energy
function I'd probably make it in the top
five for looks yeah so I think a lot of
people we don't do this very well in the
fitness space we don't communicate this
very well and this is where it gets a
little
I don't know esoteric but uh you know
look you competed at extremely high
level
um in your career
if I if you went back in time and there
was a magic wand and I could just you
know tap you on the head and boom you're
this you know high level race car driver
would it really be the same would you
have become the same person without
those trials and challenges no I mean
and I get what you're saying like
there's the this it's got to be a
lifestyle and at some point in time you
got to stop taking the drug I mean I've
seen things about it basically stopping
the stomach from digesting food at some
point in time because
um and even that it that part of the
mechanism is that it digests slower so
then some people have food that are days
old in their stomach I'm sure this is
rare but
um but it's uh yeah I mean you want to
earn your way the joy is in the journey
and um and but there's so many people
that want a shortcut and they they
really do and if there was a magic pill
to lose weight like everyone would take
it like that's why I think it's so
popular right now it's but it probably
is more indicative of a personality and
more more indicative of of that than it
is and more something on a psychological
level
an emotional level that could use some
improvement you know again we don't
communicate this uh well enough the you
know what it is is that people think
like all the amazing value and benefits
is just from being
fit and looking good they think that's
where like for example people will look
we'll think my God if I just had a lot
of money if I just had a lot of money
everything would be awesome look at the
data on people who win the lottery oh my
God a majority of them go bankrupt a
majority of um they experience like a
better life for a short period of time
then it goes back down to Baseline yeah
you've heard like Rich Dad Poor Dad yes
like no matter how much money you have
like you're kind of gonna do one or the
other you can win the lottery and still
lose it if you kind of have a poor dead
mentality and it's probably the same
with Fitness like what you're just about
to say like if you have a sort of I'm
just going to categorize like fat skinny
sort of mentality like you just it
probably has to do with your way of life
it does and uh Fitness is uh a
unassuming yet powerful vehicle for
personal growth because
you know you show up it hurts it's hard
you fail you'll learn you practice you
learn body acceptance this is what
people don't realize you do this long
enough and you actually get to a point
of body acceptance
um even though most people initially
start exercising because of maybe some
insecurities about their body
uh if you do it long enough you really
start to accept like this is this is my
body this is how I look and right and
that's interesting that you say that
because one thing I wanted to ask about
because so many of us are using social
media and
um you know what we've seen as a you
know cultivated appearance by certain
people that are promoting things to be
like I want to look like that
and what I was trying to remember
because like you're totally right about
getting to acceptance because you
realize you're working your ass off you
know you are and you're like wait a
minute
I walk around I don't see people that
look like that like that's just I'm like
I tell people I'm like seriously if you
want to look like that think about how
many people you see looking like that in
regular life almost nobody why because
it's Photoshop but then number two they
must be on drugs which leads to how many
basically Peds of sorts anabolic
enhancers that there are out there and
how many people are you looking at that
you want to look like that are totally
unhealthy yeah and uh Arthur Brooks is a
good friend of mine he's been on the
show a couple times uh he's a Harvard
Professor expert on happiness
and so he knows the data very well and
he says that beauty
contributes so Beauty being Aesthetics
how you look contributes very very
little to happiness so he says like
let's say you're on a scale of one to
ten you're a six
and you spend all kinds of time money
and effort to plastic surgery whatever
to look to get yourself up to a nine he
goes your happiness will go up a tiny
tiny fraction
it's not the case with Fitness
because it's not it makes you look good
it's the journey in the process of
showing up it's it's hard it's
acceptance It's changing your
relationship to pain you know when you
first exercise It Hurts by the way it
still hurts 10 years later but it feels
different changes your relationship to
pain boy is that carry over to uh
everyday life yeah
um it's uh it's a learning process it's
a skill it's
it's so many different things and if we
had a magic pill that gave you all of
the benefits quote unquote uh of let's
say you know Fitness you know looking
good fat loss odd stuff but you didn't
go
it's look it's it's like taking a
helicopter ride to the top of Mount
Everest beautiful view looks nice wow
that's great is it the same thing as
climbing the mountain it's not even
close like right you can't compare the
two
we don't communicate this enough with
people so what happens is people start
this journey of exercise and they just
look at the scale
and they say oh my God it's not moving
down fast enough this really sucks and
they totally ignore the fact that oh my
you know my libido's better oh I I my
mood is better uh I showed up you know
every week now for the past six weeks
and my energy is better you know this is
these are all things people tend to
ignore because we're so focused on this
like scale
and then you know you mentioned like
looking at people
um this is a unfortunate it's good to be
aware of it though but it's just
unfortunate uh aspect of human behavior
is we our happiness tends to be
connected to how we rank ourselves with
our peers if you are on social media
and you're scrolling through and you
follow all these accounts of all these
perfect bodies your brain perceives that
as people that are around you
so now you're like man I am so down far
down the totem pole in terms of beauty
that I am just which it's it's not true
it is absolutely not first of all social
media is
people's personal advertising it's
totally oh yeah totally fake also the
best photos out there too like I picked
your own like nope okay that one you
know you know it's like it's also it's
also fake from this standpoint I've met
a lot of these fitness and health
perfect looking okay you don't want to
be like a lot of them uh a lot of them
have severe body image issues disordered
eating uh they don't have good
relationships they are dysfunctional and
obsessive body obsessed
um and they'll tell it you know they'll
say that like I I this is hard for me I
don't like this doing it this is like
hell uh it's torture
um they don't go to you know family
events they don't they stress over every
macro like you don't want to be like
it's not worth it I bet no so uh I tell
people to uh and I've done this for
myself is I'll go through my algorithm
and I'll purposely modify it and change
it so that it only shows things uh to me
that make me feel better so like I get
rid of the
you know the the the the crazy news
stuff and the extremist stuff well the
compare all the comparison is the thief
of Joy stuff yes absolutely solely true
you know my parents are poor immigrants
my dad was very very poor growing up
he when he went to school up to second
grade just so people understand like he
couldn't go to school anymore couldn't
afford it had to work so he's you know
what is he nine years old
he lived in a uh like a cement house
with you know six siblings
and he likes to talk about how happy
they were he's like we didn't have
anything and we were together yeah so
you know I know we're getting a little
uh on the esoteric side here but it's
important to communicate this I can go
as far down the esoteric side as you
want aliens plant medicines like I can
go down whatever Avenue you want to go
down so feel free feel free to be as
esoteric as you like I see why you like
the show with the same people it's uh
it's uh it's interesting but we need to
communicate this well you know when I
became successful
as a trainer in the sense that I was
able to really get people
um you know good results that they were
able to sustain
this is the part that I figured out as I
was able to or I figured out how to
communicate all of the benefits
that the people were experiencing
through Fitness just
the you know my body looks different I'm
strong you know I lost weight but my
energy is better and you know I'm way
more calm and you know I noticed that
traffic doesn't bother me as much and
I'm enjoying it for those reasons yeah
um and then they were able to really see
the total value
and appreciate it and over time they
were able to develop this kind of I mean
they a lot many of them still to this
day I haven't trained anybody for eight
years but they still are consistent on
their own these are all people that were
never consistent
and it was because of that
um versus the like you know this is all
about making you look a particular way
this is all about you know making you
lose weight you know I had a one guy I
trained
where he had struggled with weight
for most of his life his goal was to
lose 35 pounds it took him three years
training with me to lose 35 pounds now
it's not because I put on 20 pounds of
muscle though well no it wasn't even I
mean yes he did put all muscle but it
wasn't because
necessarily we did things wrong it's
because we took our time we did things
right
he learned how to modify his behaviors
he learned how to focus on all of the
other benefits now he lost that 35
pounds in a six-month period at the end
of that three year
that's hilarious how'd that happen well
when you first cut you were on a bulk
the entire time for two and a half years
and then you're finally like okay you
can do a cut now yeah no it was more
like uh
she had so many
um bad associations with uh with
exercise and diet and it was just this
real negative thing for him a lot of
body image issues and so we just focused
on feeling better body acceptance he
started enjoying the fact that the the
for the mental benefits and then he
started to enjoy coming in just to see
me and everybody else in there he really
liked it and then it just clicked by the
way this was how long ago now 15 years
ago he hasn't gained a single pound back
I still talked to the guy oh yeah he
changed his psychology everything right
now before you know times he lost 30
pounds and gained it back right terrible
yeah well it's the Rich Dad Poor Dad
again it's like the mentality is what's
important you can gain get money but
you'll lose it you can get lose weight
but you'll gain it because you don't
really know how and why and have the
infrastructure to make it better yeah
because you're just in the same cycle
you know how many people lose weight
every year Millions
ninety percent of them get it back we
don't have a weight loss problem at all
everybody's like we have a weight loss
but it's not we have a keep it off
problem there's a Monsanto problem too
but you know that's that's a whole other
another problem I went to Europe this
summer for six weeks and
drank almost every day and ate pretty
much whatever and felt way different
it's true yeah that's you bring up a
good point the and I've said you know
we're now making a real hard push uh on
the show
but uh there's a uh a large
there's a huge incentive
for a lot of companies in governments
to keep us unhealthy there's a huge
incentive when you're unhealthy you're
dependent when you're unhealthy you can
be manipulated very easily when you're
unhealthy you use lots of
pharmaceuticals
when you're unhealthy your consumption
habits
are different healthy people don't
consume
in the same way that unhealthy people do
we're not the best healthy people are
not the best consumers we don't spend a
lot of money on
you know Pharmaceuticals like go to the
grocery store what percentage of the of
the products and Foods in there are
maybe Loosely directed towards unhealthy
habits oh my God probably
80 percent
I mean look at uh all products all
products all things that we consume you
know we just went through this pandemic
okay
where uh it was really scary I mean it
was a it was a concentrated effort to
scare the [__] out of everybody I think
it's pretty clear yep looking back
um and if you were sick
unhealthy uh it was it was easier for
you to be afraid it was uh it was easy
to be manipulated like if you're healthy
and fit and you take your health into
your own hands it's kind of hard to it's
harder
to manipulate uh people when they're fit
healthy and confident you know when
you're not feel confident when you don't
feel empowered
um you know you you you're easy to
manipulate so there's this anti-health
industry
that is really geared towards all of
that I mean again think of all the
products think of the products that uh
decrease activity
that make things easier think of the
products that mask symptoms so headache
pain
acid reflux heartburn you know
constipation whatever like so many
products so many products would go
bankrupt if everybody all of a sudden
became healthy and then companies and
politicians and all those people would
lose their for funding governments by
the way it's getting uh pretty
ridiculous now I'm starting to read out
articles about how
Fitness uh and gyms are toxic and not
inclusive
um how they're alt-right it was really
strange things I'm reading I never
thought I'd read that's right oh it's
crazy it's the most include you know
this the most inclusive place you'll
ever go is a gym yeah I mean I mean like
the most I mean like talk all you want
about CrossFit nobody gets cheered for
more than the last person in a workout
like I'm watching it on the floor at the
games and they're all out there cheering
for the person that is still not done
yet and these are the top 20 Elite human
beings in the world like it is like
Fitness is so inclusive I mean I go to
them all the time and you walk by and
you smile at people and you look and you
know there's you're not you're not
elbowing your way through you're not a
dick to anybody it's like you're like
cool you showed up so did I the most uh
inclusive gyms are the most hardcore
which is so funny you go to the one with
all the shock and the crazy lifters and
all that stuff
and if you're just you're in there
trying like they want to help you they
they support you it's so it's so great
nobody cares how do you vote who you
sleep with nobody cares what your
religion when they shut down beaches and
trails during during covid like as if
you were gonna get something at the
beach like or or like hiking like that
is just like it's just ludicrous I do
laugh at those images on social media of
like don't forget we did this like there
are people like what they would wear and
their mechanisms and I mean it's just
like
it was it was a lot of fear and it was a
lot of uh a lot of manipulation uh and
uh it was I mean I think it was a good
potential Learning lesson I think a lot
of people are still traumatized
unfortunately well they're probably in
areas that it was made that way or or do
a job that had to ingrain it into them
as a as a pattern in a in a really
deeply rooted fear
um you know and I feel for those people
who lived in areas where it was super
prevalent as far as rules go and also
the people that had to
you know be involved in jobs that you
know would force them to you know stay
in that state yeah you know gyms were
shut down the longest
and they did a couple studies on the
transmission of covid in gyms and it was
actually one of the safest places you
could go
and people like well how's that possible
people are working out next to each
other the last place people go and they
don't feel good as a gym so it's just
there's a bit of a self-selection bias
sick people don't work out
that's why that's why you didn't see
this huge transmit but I mean I mean you
get you had you've forced people to stay
at home in in poor health I mean the the
side effects of all that
cause more deaths uh yeah for sure virus
itself you know and I think everybody
realizes that even the ones that don't
want to say it it's like they can at
least accept some level of like okay
that was probably a little much you know
yeah and uh the people in the fitness
and health space were the most resistant
all of us were like oh wait hold on a
second uh you know you told us
for years that margarine was better than
butter
you told us for years that egg yolks are
going to kill me
you told me for years that uh you know
whole I should eat mostly you know
carbohydrates from breads stay away from
saturated fat and steak yes like your
cholesterol matter number matters
and so all of us were like uh I'm gonna
I'm a little yeah I'm gonna be a little
skeptical when you tell me that I can't
go to the beach so it's a hard pass yeah
no thanks I mean do you see any end in
sight these are the kind of questions I
get to and I ask myself I'm like I'm
literally like am I just gonna have to
move I'm going to Europe this summer I
was like
live here you know like I mean I
health is so important to me like like
you can go to you know whole check Whole
Foods and go buy the best possible
options you can be even at your farmer's
market but you can't stop like what's
being dumped into the air you can't stop
what kind of seeds you get like there's
just only so much you can do yeah you
need to mitigate your
other threats uh the biggest offenders
would be the um chemicals or the things
that we put on our skin that's a big one
so like makeups lotions those things are
are pretty big offenders
um the Plastics that we store food and
water in that's a big offender
um and then I would avoid glyphosates as
much as possible they have kind of an
antibiotic effect on the microbiome so
that's kind of that's throwing people
off
and then you know keep yourself fit you
know when you are fit your body's detox
pathways are so much more effective I
mean just sweating alone is a wonderful
way to
spare on your rid uh itself of you know
toxic chemicals and stuff like that the
lymphatic system keeps moving as you
move and jump and move around I mean
yeah having a good balanced hormones
because you're fit helps offset the
xenoestrogens that you'll you know
unless I mean you're going to be exposed
to that's I mean that's pretty much it I
mean if you want to go if we really want
to go like
you know big picture here
if we changed our consumption habits
because we were all moving towards being
healthy then the markets would shift and
we would see a lot we would see
innovation
because people are like well it's
cheaper to eat this way or whatever only
because that's where the market pushes
it you know when the demand is high
markets are really good at finding cheap
ways to deliver
what we want but if we're all you know
pushing in a healthy direction then we
would see
um the markets move and innovate in that
direction so they would find
Alternatives this is just this is what
producers do absolutely if we don't
participate it doesn't exist you know do
you think the newspaper's [__] stop
buying it and I promise you it'll be
gone pretty quickly because people are
not in the business of losing money 100
so you would see uh markets change you
would see Innovation move towards uh
products uh that were yeah
yeah but we all have to kind of move in
that uh in that direction it takes a
little bit of awareness yeah but you
know you ask like when is this all going
to change
I don't know I think we're we're in
Uncharted Territory with
um distractions of social media they're
getting really good at
uh keeping us uh distracted and not
present it's only going to get more
powerful
uh so I don't know I don't know what
that what that's gonna look like it
almost feels like you know it's funny I
was like I was just talking to guys the
other day
we went to this event in Tennessee and
um there were I saw a lot of uh
Mennonites I think they're called right
okay and uh so I looked them up because
you could tell who they are they have a
certain haircut they dress a particular
way it's like this is interesting like
what do they do so I looked them up then
I read about the Amish and it sounds so
like extreme but then part of me is like
you know they kind of figured it out a
little bit you know right right they
have like no cancer or something no like
there's certain like metrics in which
exist in those communities that um are
exceptional and healthy uh they grow
their own food they have a little stress
there's no technology there's probably
really low emfs and yeah I was like I
wonder so it might take some some a
little bit of radical changes but okay
look not to discourage anybody
like step one uh you know structure some
exercise strength training would be your
most effective form for a couple days a
week move more throughout the day
walking after meals is good taking the
stairs is good yeah you know parking far
from your destination is good that all
adds up people think that that's does it
make a big difference makes a huge
difference
um eat whole natural foods and that's 90
that's literally 90 you know the whole
Natural Foods one is a big one that's a
huge one most people would lose
most the weight that they want if all
they did was eat whole natural foods and
didn't even worry about cutting their
calories or less if they just did that
your your consumption tends to get
self-regulated in a much more because
your body doesn't want to be obese
there's this weird
misconception that humans are like
eating machines you just put food in
front of us we'll eat it that's not true
we have palate fatigue you know our body
will tell us when to stop but if you eat
foods that are engineered to make you
overeat which is that's what they're
designed to do
uh then you are going over if you avoid
them I you know I would get clients to
lose on average about 15 to 20 pounds
just from that I would tell I tell them
eat as much as you want just eat whole
natural foods and they'd lose 15 to 20
pounds almost every time
well I mean that you know back to I'd
like to have you explain the sort of
um
you know process of it but I was a huge
Epiphany for me just listening to the
process of sort of metabolism and muscle
and calorie consumption and you know for
me at the beginning of the year pretty
much been on like almost a reverse diet
all year like building muscle needing
understanding that you literally can't
build muscle without account like the
calories to do it so you get all these
people that go work out and they you
know pushing their ass off eating um
like the difference between 1200 and
1700 calories is like a whole giant meal
like it is heaven right like but they're
trying to eat that and working out
really hard at the same time and then
you end up in this sort of calorie
prison and I think a lot of people get
there I really you know and so
understanding that mechanism just so you
can have a healthy lifestyle so you can
eat the steak and the eggs and the
potatoes and the fruits and and not
really worry because but people really
do get in the hole I believe it you know
they're in the they're in their 12 1500
calorie whole yeah so Chris cresser gave
me a great example he said
if I gave you five plain boiled potatoes
and I told you to eat them all in 30
minutes would you be able to it's like
probably not like I would I would just I
would gag after the third one right he
says if I gave you a family-sized bag of
Lay's potato chips would you be able to
and I said well yeah and he goes it's
about the same amount of potatoes it's
just uh one of them has been engineered
to be hyper palatable
studies show consistently these are the
best studies we have on diet diet
studies are hard because they tend to be
observational so
it's like what did you eat how many
tomatoes did you eat last week so it's
like survey stuff they're notoriously
inaccurate
but the studies they've done on
processed foods is they actually have
people go into a
a lab and they take two groups and they
give them unlimited access to either
heavily processed foods so foods that
you find in wrappers and boxes
versus whole Natural Foods you know one
single ingredient types foods like
fruits vegetables meats eggs that kind
of stuff
and they even control the macros uh in
other words you know similar protein fat
carb type you know breakdown and then
they have them eat as much as they want
and then they switch them so that now
this group goes in this room this group
goes in that room and you're looking at
about 600 calorie defense difference
per day 600 calorie difference
per day of just eating until you're
satisfied it's just one type of food the
science that goes into engineering
heavily processed food is so crazy
have you had a food scientist come on
your show no it'll blow your mind
right oh it's it's such a crazy science
everything from the
the mouth feel
the texture the lingering taste uh
crunch
the residue that leaves on your fingers
of course the taste like they have got
it down to a science to where they can
create these foods that uh are so hyper
palatable that would never exist in
nature
that when you eat them your when your
body is satiated when it's ready it's
like I've had enough
you've gone above and beyond where your
body would normally yeah you've just
over eaten is what's happened
so when people just avoid those Foods
they eat less without realizing they eat
until they're full but they don't
realize that they're actually eating
less and then you know what you were
saying about fueling the body
um yeah you when you send the signal to
build muscle if you don't have the the
building blocks not gonna happen
so you have to have the proteins you
have to have some of the calories to do
that and then your metabolism speeds up
that's great you know
uh I would get a person's metabolism to
boost by on average you know anywhere
between five to eight hundred calories a
day
uh some people a lot more depending on
how low they were like that's a big you
know 500 calories is like an hour and a
half of cardio like what if you could
just burn that
on your own that's pretty amazing yeah
it's a really good strategy uh for most
people to approach things you know so to
not be afraid of the weight right
because you know if you weigh 100 pounds
that's you also when your weight goes
down you require less calories for the
machine so if you can be the same height
but weigh 135 instead of 100 and look
great because it's muscle then you just
have way more flexibility with your life
yeah I used to tell my uh typically my
female clients to take their scales and
put it in the closet don't weigh
yourself
we'll check in in a few months and
everyone was shocked they were always so
shocked I would get this comment I used
to love this they'd come in and they'd
say man people keep commenting on how
much weight I've lost everybody's like
oh my God he lost so much weight you
look so good god oh and then I'd have
fun with them and I'd weigh them and
they'd weigh themselves and they would
be the same
and they'd say this is wait I haven't
lost any weights well no you lost body
fat you gained some muscle
but everybody's commenting on how much
weight you've lost because you're
smaller and you look different yeah
absolutely without running you mentioned
running yeah I mean if you want stamina
endurance and you like that form of
activity it's great terrible way to lose
weight though uh because it uh teaches
the body to become more efficient with
calories it actually slows down the
metabolism if if that's all you do
especially in combination with a low
calorie diet so what you're doing
remember whatever you're doing with
exercise
you're telling your body to get better
at what you're doing okay so let's look
at running
running requires stamina endurance
doesn't require much strength at all
and while you're doing it you burn a lot
of calories which is true so the body is
like okay we need to become better at
this uh we don't need much strength
we're burning a lot of calories that's
become more efficient so it loses muscle
is what it was what it does so when you
look at Weight Loss through running and
calorie restriction typically half of
the weight or close to half the weight
that's lost is muscle
so you end up with a slower metabolism
so it's like I lost 10 pounds then I
plateau
and then uh okay I need to run more I
need yeah right up in this really crazy
unsustainable place where you're eating
uh less and less and less running more
and more and more
and they're getting 1200 calories a day
I'm running five days a week like this
is not sustainable for me if I go off
for a week I gain all this weight so
what what do you tell people like that
so that's somebody somebody's comes to
you and they do that they're running all
the time they have low calories what's
the next step
so what I have them do is I slowly
reduce the running and I start
introducing strength training and I do
what's called the reverse diet you just
thought you just mentioned that so
reverse diet is where we
slowly increase their calories and make
sure their protein intake is high that's
really important so how high can it get
because I definitely I'm like I weigh
about 115 and I probably eat about 130
grams a day oh you're fine I mean can
you eat even more than that yeah I could
I mean unless you you experience like
gastro uh issues or distress
but I I tell people aim for about a gram
of protein per pound of uh of Target
body weight
um it's just the upper limit of benefit
from protein is right around there
eating more isn't bad okay especially if
you like it and you enjoy it but unless
you again you some people might notice
digestive issues uh from that because
they they'll maybe not eating enough
fiber as a result other than that though
there's no problem proteins I mean we
so you get them working out you get them
lifting you dwindle the running so it's
not cold turkey on them and then you
reverse diet them up
yeah and we see a metabolism boost how
long does it take for them to be able to
get to a point generally what do you
like the recommendation like hey I need
you to be patient for six months or I
need you to be patient for a year or
three months before they can get to the
point where they're really only strength
training for the most part and their
calories are in a much more human range
there's a huge variance with that it
depends how long they've been doing what
they're doing how much quote-unquote
damage has been caused
if there's a lot of accumulated stress
on the body if we see
adrenal like uh what is it um
not adrenal fatigue that's the old term
people hate that because it's not really
what's happening but you see this kind
of dysfunction between
or dysregulation between the adrenals
and the hypothalamus and so you get this
it's a result Spike club like that was
me mine was all flipped yeah it could
take a while for some people some people
it's actually quite quite fast but if I
have like let's say I have a female
client who's been beating the crap out
of herself for years and years and years
she's eating 1200 calories a day
um it could take us uh you know six
months to a year yeah we get to that but
by the way that entire time she's
improving so it's not like nothing
happened
she's seeing changes uh and feeling good
yeah other cases it happens uh much
faster but it can take a while sometimes
so people should need to be patient I
mean if you've been chronically
stressing your body
you know your CNS probably has a memory
uh are on all of that and so it kind of
wants to hold on because you know for 10
years you've been beating the crap out
of me and under eating yeah it could
take a little while sometimes depending
on the person oh how long do you see the
body being able to tolerate
abuse
like if somebody's sitting there going
man I've been doing this Jam for a while
like I work out super hard I'm super
calorie restrictive
how long can they get away with it
usually
boy that's that's a tough question the
the the body's ability
to tolerate ridiculous accumulated
amounts of stress
and our ability to deny the fact that
that's happening it can be pretty wild I
mean I've talked to people where the
signs are so obvious
people losing hair
is a brittle
um like no sex drive uh skin is just you
know they have skin issues
chronic gut issues they've developed
such a dysfunctional relationship with
the process that they're scared
to back off uh the exercise it's like
they're abusing it like a drug
um so it's pretty remarkable on the
extreme end I've seen some pretty
crazy situations where it's like okay
um I'm gonna work with you but I'd also
like you to work with the therapist
as breaking the chains that you have
connecting you to this abuse
is going to be really hard whatever
you're running from whatever you're
distracting yourself from is going to
surface as we stop uh you know abusing
this
this you know whatever this drug we're
turning into a drug totally so people
will will stop doing all that and then
they have to deal with some of their
feelings or
some of the other challenges you're
really good at the psychological part
when you guys have your callers come on
like you've got them pinned out you have
a very good you're a good pattern
recognizer you can really understand
where somebody's at very quickly which I
super appreciate well that's uh half the
time is I'm talking to myself uh because
this is the struggle that I've dealt
with my entire life
no better example than yourself and
having gotten through it to be able to
identify it for sure yeah I got into
this because of audio image issues and I
you know so so that the other half of it
said
we we all trained a lot of people for a
long time you know
I always speak highly of uh trainers and
coaches because I used the other day I
used baseball as a as an example I said
you know baseball is a funny sport where
if you hit you know you're batting 300
right you hit the ball three out of ten
times you're doing great right
in Fitness if you're a trainer and 30 of
your clients get results that stick like
you're crushing you are killing it it's
a weird job where you have to accept
like tons of failure
it's hard you don't make a lot of money
like if you if you get into fitness
because you want to make a lot of money
it's a wrong space it's not it's not an
easy money making space so the people
that stick to it genuinely genuinely
love and have a passion for helping
people and my co-host and I all had that
in common we just really really wanted
to help
people and you have to have a lot of
tough conversations with yourself
through that process it's like this
isn't working or why aren't my clients
succeeding or I keep running into this
problem or man I blew that woman out of
the gym and she's not coming back what
did I do wrong like what's going on and
then I worked a lot with other
practitioners at one point I realized
that there was a lot I could learn from
therapists
acupuncturists functional medicine
practitioners
Body Work Specialists like massage
therapists meditation specialists
so I'd work with them
and uh I would learn I remember when I
learned uh belly breathing from
a meditation expert so they taught me
about how to teach someone how to belly
breathe so excited because I had felt
like what it did to me
and I took a client and we laid down on
the ground I had a small Studio
and there was a room where I could kind
of make it dark and relaxing and I said
hey you know because I knew this person
was like just chronically stressed they
say hey we're going to try some belly
breathing so I had her lay on the ground
and you know she put one hand in her
belly one hand in her chest and I said
you know the way you teach it is you're
the hand that's on your belly should
rise first and fully before the chest
and let's do this
and we did this in in five minutes and
she started crying and I remember first
off I was very unprepared for that it's
like oh my God what do I do
uh but then I realized how much ReStore
in our bodies that we just keep you know
locked up
and I learned that from the meditation
specialist I learned from uh therapists
with a body image issue clients like I
would get uh you know a kid who
just came out of anorexia
um and the therapist said do not weigh
them don't focus on how they look don't
focus on body fat percentage
and I thought I'm going to focus on
performance like how strong they are and
it was just so effective like I could
get somebody who's anorexic or who just
came out of
anorexia focus on performance
and then they were doing the right
things because you have to do the right
things to get stronger right
you can't cheat that you can't cheat
getting stronger yes so uh yeah just man
we I mean we're there's a lot that we
learned
through that process I feel very blessed
to have worked with uh you know all
these people I I had to go through that
myself I went through a period where
I had uh sat down with a couple
practitioners in my Wellness Studio I
had my own health issues
because I've been ignoring my own body
and I sat down with them uh just totally
distraught and I said uh look I I can't
figure this out and I'm just gonna do
what you tell me
and what I did
through that process I did gut testing
and hormone testing and uh you know
started doing meditation all that stuff
change my workouts is a couple things I
had to do is I had to stop looking in
the mirror so that's weird so it's like
you know brush your teeth comb your hair
get out
so I stopped looking in the mirror
because that was triggering
um I didn't weigh myself and I
consciously stopped paying attention to
the weight that I was putting on the bar
which was pretty hard to do and uh the
the evolution that I got out of that was
massive it was so it was so huge I
at the end of that year I realized I
looked better
than I did when I was so focused on how
I looked and then it really dawned on me
I was like man if I'm just healthy I'm
gonna look good
you know it's like always wonder if
there's some kind of thoughts become
things little system happening where
when you're you're doing the right stuff
you're getting stronger whatever the
things are that you're trying to do you
kind of Envision that you'll get you'll
look better from it you'll be stronger
you'll you know you just yeah you're
feeling yourself a little bit more and
instead when you look in the if you're
looking in the mirror you just pick out
the negatives and they get exacerbated
and you almost I don't know you keep
yourself stuck from the thoughts that
you're thinking in real life
health is the most attractive thing the
reason why I say in real life is because
you can get away with
poor health looks good on a camera or
pictures or video
uh but when you meet it's funny it's so
funny early on when we started the show
we're trying to figure out how to like
reach a larger audience and you find
these Instagram influencers with all
these followers you meet them in person
and they don't they look distorted like
oh look something something doesn't look
right or you
bodybuilding show or something like that
and you see people backstage you look at
them in the face and you're like oh you
don't look healthy at all this doesn't
look good
um in real life good health is very
attractive
so the the stuff that we're aiming for
really are just side effects of good
health they're not the main effects
so it's the health that you really want
to go after you know it's like you ever
talk to somebody
and because they're and by the way when
I say health I don't just mean physical
it's like you know mental emotional
you ever meet someone who's emotionally
mentally spiritually healthy you talk
with them for a few minutes and they're
just
you're drawn to them like whatever what
a grounded healthy person right that's
that's what's attractive we're all
trying to be more attractive I guess or
more accepted
uh it's like you know just be healthy
that's really the yeah well I mean from
the mental emotional standpoint they
don't they're not projecting as much
they're not getting triggered they're
not it's like a much more balanced
conversation they're less egotistical
um because they have less insecurities
yeah I mean you can the conversation is
easy
um Pleasant confident but patient
yes yes
uh absolutely even even as we you know
God we have we live in a culture that we
just uh we chastise age like getting
older is like this terrible thing you
meet someone who's
healthy
uh who's you know 60 70
like they're attractive like you sit
down with them you're like man this is a
very like I want to be around this
person
so it's all about Good Health what we've
done is we've taken the symptoms
or the side effects of good health
and we've distorted the [__] out of them
really halves like uh
with all kinds of insanity uh but you
just got to be healthy that's really
what's the most attractive thing stop
comparing yourself to other people yeah
get there you'll totally get there it's
it's within everybody's grasp that's
what that's what I try to communicate
the most you know
the hard thing was like you sit down you
want to have this conversation and get
all the like this do this do that do
this do that and really what it ends up
coming down to is
this overall health of like consistency
self-respect
patience moderation
con you know adapting it to your life
your lifestyle your body how things
react I mean even when it comes to food
like I've gone through every iteration
of what you can possibly try and
finally hit me I was like oh
I already know like you already
intuitively know what works for you
because it agrees with you like I
remember forever I didn't eat eggs
because every time I took a blood test
it said you have high sensitivity eggs
is off the charts and I have eight eggs
every single day this year I didn't eat
eggs for probably like I don't know
eight years or so like almost never and
I was like I never noticed a problem but
damn that test you know and now I'm like
oh okay well it says don't eat
cauliflower or it says I can eat
cauliflower but I tell you what I put
that thing I eat that and it is no bueno
so it's like you're you really freaking
know like you are well aware of it it's
just that we want clear and concise
answers on everything but it is a matter
of being consistent trying it out for
yourself and having enough self-respect
to stick with the program self-care and
self-love if you if you work out because
you're taking care of yourself you're
gonna you're gonna do it in an
appropriate way because that means
sometimes that looks like a hard workout
sometimes that means it's an easy
workout sometimes it means you take the
day off because you're actually trying
to take care of yourself same thing with
diet
if I'm trying to take care of myself in
a genuine way I'm probably going to eat
what would be considered classically
healthy most of the time but sometimes
taking care of myself is you know
sitting down with my friends and having
pizza
so uh yeah that's where the balance of
moderation comes from but yeah you're
right we've been taught to ignore our
bodies dot you know that Western
medicine does this
you know how many times you go to the
doctor or the doctor's like you don't
feel that that's not what's happening or
you know right yeah it's bath lighting
oh it's insane it's insane yeah yeah
exactly exactly well
look I have so many more questions but I
think that'll that's a really good sum
of all the evils and all the good and um
you know I just super respect you for
all the hard work you put in and
generosity and you give away the program
to so many people and you you've built
so many of them to adapt to so many
different Lifestyles and you guys are
honest and you tell the truth and
um I really really appreciate that and
it's why I keep why listen to you guys
so often thank you so much I really
appreciate that and uh you know coming
from you you know the guys and I were
fans of yours back in the day so when I
heard you listen to the show we're like
what oh my God that's so cool so yeah I
appreciate the kind words thank you yeah
you're welcome thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button